what do you think is the key to your
success in the six years what would you
pinpoint as the one thing or the handful
of things that have gotten you to where
you are now hmm um I think I think it's
just uh III think just the passion right
the drive um I don't know I there's just
just that motivation you don't I mean
that motivation to sort of you know
reach reach just the different goals
that I have in mind and even sometimes
like people will say I'll write down you
know your goals what are your goals for
5-10 years and it's like it's so it's
always hard for me to write those things
down cuz sometimes I almost feel like
limited by that because you know I feel
like in a weird way you know that they
create such a pressure that lets say i
said a year from now i want to book five
films and then I year from now I've only
booked three films and two commercials
or whatever like that's a huge
accomplishment like I feel like they'll
should be celebrated you know in a weird
way but then I now feel like I didn't do
my five films that I kind of set out for
you know and I see a lot of people get
held back by that sometimes you know so
I don't know it's always hard for me to
just write down like what my you know
thoughts and plans are specifically I
just kind of know like I just and I just
kind of want to keep going you know and
and I don't have you know a specific
thing in mind to reach but I just like I
said it's just about honestly just keep
on doing what what's making me happy it
really is it sounds cliche but that's
kind of what what drives me the most you
know and and I love what I do I love
working with people and I just I you
know I need to pay bills obviously and i
need to you know and I there things that
I do want to accomplish through that but
um I don't know i mean it's it's a
really cool thing to be able to just you
know jump on set today and play you know
the everyman guy from next door and then
jump on set tomorrow and play like a
crazy cop or or serial killer the next
day and it's just like those are all
cool things that we all do right like
we'd love halloween because we get the
dress up with somebody else or something
else and it's like I get to do that
every day or you know not every day but
you know often you know and and an
audition for the possibility to do that
you know often so I i don't know i love
variety
I'm also somebody to that like I love
movies because I love being so into this
world of you know whatever it is for
three months and then you go home the
next day and it's like well that's gone
and it's sad it's kind of like
graduating from high school or whatever
school you know every time because you
we meet these people and you work with
these people and you know you get so
close and you know you you just get to
know each other so well and then all of
a sudden it's gone you know I mean and
you know you stay in touch with people
but it's just such a weird thing you
know we do this all the time so there
are those sort of pros and cons to it
but I love that I love that about it you
know i love that I can you know yeah be
filming here and then for the summer go
to Columbia and film in the middle of
Columbia you know a film and then come
back and then do a toyota commercial and
play you a car salesman and you know I
it's just uh I love the variety that it
provides like I love seeing different
things in life and experiences in life
so so this is just a fun way for me to
do that and to be able to just make
believe like I'm such a I'm such a kid
like I really you know at heart like I
you know I've always been that class
clown and you know I'm a big prankster
with friends and and and I think people
just get that about me and I mean this
is you know what better weekend to sort
of play than than to be able to do this
so that alone is rewarding you know
enough you know for me and and i also
just you know I i think what drives me
to it was like I want everything I do to
be the best thing that it that I want it
to be the best thing that I've ever done
so it's like I'll do this film and then
this film I expect like I want to work
towards that being the best thing I've
ever done if I die tomorrow they will
say that's definitely the best thing
he's done you know and have each film be
that you know and just keep growing you
know like I don't want it to be where
and yeah in their early career they were
great you know what I mean like and we
know those those people like I just want
to continue to grow and continue to to
do better work and so those two things
you know are you know having fun and
then just just getting better each time
you know
and and you know it's storytelling and
for me for me I think like you know our
premier is a big deal people were asking
me and I was like you know it's so
special to me whether there's one or 10
or 20 or 100 2000 people at our premiere
because our film is incomplete our whole
processed it's all in vain until we get
that first audience there you know it
you don't make it for yourself I didn't
make the film for me you know like
obviously we make it for us you know we
have to be happy with it but like I mean
it for you and you know for for you and
everybody else it's like I for me the
whole process whether it's a play TV
show a film you know whatever it is in
entertainment it's not a complete
process until we bring in the audience
you know to an audience watches this
thing and can relate to it you know and
and that changes everything instantly
like when you're doing theater you
rehearse for months but then that whole
process changes once an audience comes
in because now I have to time things a
little differently because they're
laughing or they're crying or they're
missing or booing whatever it is but
that's what's so dynamic about it and
what what creates such a rush has a
theater performer because you have to be
live with them and and responsive and
listen to them the film you know even
though i can't hear everybody you know
the film can be released on netflix and
and I may not be able to see how people
respond to it or hear but you know you
see reviews and you see people write
comments and stuff and and and it's part
of that evolution of the growth right
like as a filmmaker it's like I don't
think like as an actor I'm gonna make
one film and be done with the rest my
life like I have years of longevity in
my mind love you know what I want to do
and and same as the filmmakers a
producer it's like so I'm reading these
things engaging how I can be better for
the next time you know and you're not
gonna please everybody and you can't you
know get every single thing right that
every person is gonna be happy in the
world you know but you know there's
commonality sometimes that you sense and
and and things I feel like you need to
be able to grow and adapt you know for
and sometimes maybe it's just like okay
maybe this person in my opinion was not
right but that's what they like and it's
like okay maybe I could just simply say
I'm sorry you didn't like this film but
like a year ago I did this so maybe
you'd like this better you know check
this out so it's a it's a comedy as
opposed to horror film you know any
means so you can also relate
people in different ways and different
things so I think you know that process
of having an audience is always the most
important thing we all do it for an
audience you know I mean someone's gonna
watch this video and you know it doesn't
end with just us doing it so I think
that that is uh that's that's a huge
part of the process
you